[Música]
la tensión entre algunos actores
internacionales ha trascendido a la
instancia espacial rusia anunció su
retiro de la estación espacial
internacional a partir del 2024 tras
casi 20 años de colaboración entre los
programas espaciales de la nasa y
roscósmos veamos
cosmonautas rusos a bordo de la estación
espacial internacional una realidad
desde hace más de 20 años pero pronto la
imagen pertenecerá al pasado es lo que
anunció el nuevo jefe de la agencia
espacial rusa durante una conversación
con vladímir putin en el kremlin
sin duda cumpliremos todas nuestras
obligaciones con nuestros socios pero la
decisión de dejar la estación después de
2024 está tomada
la nasa asegura que no ha sido
notificada oficialmente de la retirada
de rusia después de 2024
la estación espacial internacional es
una de las pocas cooperaciones que aún
existen entre moscú y washington en el
lado ruso ya se están preparando para el
futuro la nueva prioridad para el
programa espacial nacional una estación
orbital rusa que podría parecerse a esto
y creo que para entonces empezaremos a
crear una estación orbital rusa sur
afectado por las fuertes sanciones
occidentales de los últimos meses y la
corrupción generalizada el sector
aerospacial ruso se encuentra según las
propias autoridades en una situación
difícil esto contrasta con china que
debería completar su propia estación
espacial a finales de año una hazaña
tecnológica lograda en menos de dos años
el retiro de rusia de la estación
espacial internacional sin duda alguna
pues representa un cambio en esa digamos
carrera espacial genera nuevas alianzas
pero cómo está entonces la disputa por
la conquista del espacio china como lo
veíamos cada vez toma más fuerza con sus
planes y misiones y está determinada a
establecerse en el espacio
principalmente en nuestro satélite
natural en la luna a que está apostando
entonces eeuu que es el país junto con
rusia y entonces la unión soviética los
que lideraban la carrera espacial
también a que le está apostando entonces
rusia y hay un actor nuevo los emiratos
árabes unidos- que también están
desarrollando un programa espacial es el
espacio un nuevo escenario de tensión y
discrepancias entre las potencias
mundiales la lucha por la conquista del
espacio es entonces nuestro tema de
análisis hoy en el debate de france 24
para conversar sobre este tema saludamos
a rodrigo díaz es investigador del
centro de excelencia en astrofísica y
tecnologías afines él se conecta desde
la ciudad de munich en baviera en el sur
de alemania y desde la ciudad de buenos
aires- en la argentina a esta
conversación claudio martínez astrónomo
e investigador de la fundación azara le
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar todas
sus preguntas y comentarios a través de
las redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram y en facebook en donde no se
encuentran como arroba france24 guión
bajo s
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal y
la etiqueta ese numeral el debate efe 24
también pueden seguir nuestra señal en
streaming a través de youtube y
aprovecho para saludar a las personas
que están escuchando nuestro podcast
recuerden que todo el contenido del
programa ya está disponible en
diferentes plataformas en app el podcast
en spotify deezer y junín
bueno pues comienzo entonces dándole la
palabra a rodrigo en la ciudad de munich
en el sur de alemania punto de partida
para conocer opiniones de los invitados
como me gusta llamar a la primera
pregunta rodrigo bienvenido al programa
gracias por acompañarnos y entonces cómo
se encuentra esta carrera espacial
después de este anuncio de rusia de
retirarse de la estación espacial
internacional algo que va a suceder en
el 2024 pero entonces como se están
equilibrando las cargas cómo están los
diferentes programas espaciales vigentes
pues ya santiago bueno es muy
interesante lo que está pasando porque
estamos viendo no sólo ya estos dos
protagonistas
eeuu y rusia sino también como bien
decía la nota china emiratos árabes
india que están empezando también a dar
pasos gigantes respecto a la exploración
espacial los eeuu y rusia no es nuevo
porque ya desde la anexión de crimea en
el año 2014 que eeuu se empezó a
preparar para no depender de rusia
en términos de mantener la estación
espacial internacional y por eso que
empezaron a desarrollar estas con la
empresa privada como por ejemplo space
ex con el fin de poder encontrar una
forma de llevar sus astronautas a la
estación espacial internacional que en
el pasado se hacía con cohete ruso y que
últimamente se ha hecho a través de
spacex entonces este quiebre que se
produce obviamente por la invasión de
rusia ucrania no es algo que pilla de
forma desprevenida a la nasa sino por el
contrario ellos se han estado preparando
entendiendo de que esta alianza rusa
estadounidense es cada vez más
complicada por lo tanto está empujando a
eeuu a ser más independiente y en el
fondo encontrar fuerza en su empresa
privada y está acercando a rusia cada
vez más a china con el objetivo de poder
perseguir en el fondo misiones en
conjunto porque vale la pena aclarar
cuando eeuu puso fin a su programa de
los transbordadores espaciales como
medio de transporte para llegar al
espacio eeuu y quedó sin con que llegar
al espacio y la única puerta digamos que
había era en las naves ayuda a través
del cosmódromo de baikonur en kazajistán
le doy la bienvenida ahora a claudio en
la ciudad de buenos aires muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros y bueno quiero
conocer su opinión punto de partida cómo
está entonces la carrera espacial en
este momento ya rodrigo nos daba un poco
su perspectiva cuál es la suya clave
bien más o menos la misma tenemos es un
negocio muy grande el de la exploración
espacial y como bien decía rusia es el
que tiene los lanzadores más baratos
entonces era era natural que eeuu
intentará hacer esto pero como vieron
que se estaba complicando políticamente
todo ya sabemos todos que en algún
momento iba a haber algún inconveniente
entre rusia y eeuu ellos previendo luego
empezaron a impulsar el desarrollo de
las empresas privadas como para poder
lograr el tener toda la todo lo que sea
acceso a la estación espacial
internacional pero desde hace ya unos
cuantos años estaba viendo que rusia en
algún momento iba a alejarse de la
estación espacial
audio continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa está menciona que
esto es un negocio que tanto esto es un
negocio para invertir en términos de
prestigio de la imagen de estos países
que se disputan esta carrera espacial
o qué tan rentable puede ser para estos
países debe ser un negocio absolutamente
millonario y a la nasa le ha costado a
lo largo de los últimos años un poco
apretarse el cinturón porque es un
programa ambicioso costoso y el gobierno
ha tenido que priorizar algunas otras
esferas y ha recortado un poco los
fondos para la investigación espacial
sigue justamente el problema que tiene
la nasa es que su presupuesto depende
directamente del gobierno en cambio las
empresas privadas pueden tener otras
opciones aparte han desarrollado
vectores o sea lanzadores cohetes mucho
más que se pueden reutilizar más
económicos entonces es una cosa
importante lo que se está logrando y
obviamente es un prestigio importante
imagínense en un país como la india que
tenga alguna nave yendo a marte aunque
ya ha llegado al planeta marte es una
cosa de prestigio muy muy importante a
nivel político y opera por supuesto como
desarrollo tecnológico
rodrigo regreso con usted en la ciudad
de munich hablamos de esto como un
negocio también una necesidad científica
por entender que lo que pasa en el
espacio exterior más allá de las
fronteras que puede tener nuestro
planeta pero tiempo de las reglas en
esta carrera internacional por la lucha
por llegar a marte por explorar la luna
por explorar otros planetas vecinos
quien pone aquí las reglas
bueno yo creo que estamos en necesidad
de un nuevo tratado espacial el que
tenemos actualmente es de los años 60 y
simplemente en el fondo edita de que se
pongan armas de destrucción masiva o se
utilicen desde el espacio pero las
posibilidades que estamos viendo ahora a
través de estas nuevas misiones
espaciales de empezar a hablar de vamos
a poner bases en la luna vamos a
construir ciudades en marte que antes
parecía en los años 60 probablemente una
utopía pero ya es una realidad y podría
ocurrir durante esta década en el fondo
requiere que empecemos a conversar como
humanidad
reformar este en el fondo tratado
espacial para que podamos definir cuáles
son las reglas del juego por ejemplo la
superficie de la luna en su parte en el
su polo sur es rica en agua por eso es
que china y eeuu de forma paralela tiene
mucho interés en establecer bases en esa
parte de la luna en este minuto así como
están las cosas casi quién llega primero
verdades se instala pero sería muy bueno
que empezáramos a debatir y a pensar ok
cómo vamos a poder administrar estos
espacios y en el futuro que puede sonar
un poco loco pero cuando ya podamos ir y
por ejemplo extraer minerales verdad ir
a asteroides y traernos de vuelta
metales preciosos cuáles van a ser las
reglas cómo vamos a definir quién puede
ir a quién le pertenece lo que se extrae
todo ese tipo de cosas merece una
revisión y los tratados actuales no
incluyen reglas al respecto claudio su
opinión sobre este tema de las reglas
hay en el mediano o corto plazo una
negociación entre estas partes ahora que
hay tanta tensión entre moscú y
washington y beijing por todo lo que
sucede acá en la tierra
el escenario del espacio será que puede
haber una negociación pronto en este
momento lo veo bastante difícil que
pueda haber una negociación pero como
bien dice rodrigo el desarrollo de la
carrera espacial que ahora sería más un
poco más comercial el poder tener la
parte minera es algo que se va a tener
que redefinir porque en este momento lo
único que hay es decir que bueno la luna
es un lugar instarlos todos los lugares
fuera de la tierra son internacionales o
sea son de todos los países pero a
partir de allí no dice nada la
extracción como se haría como se
repartiría quien podría hacerlo quien no
de qué forma eso hay que redefinir lo
toda una parte legal muy compleja que no
está ha tenido en cuenta en este momento
y por el momento con las tensiones
políticas que hay en la tierra va a
quedar para mucho más adelante inclusive
todo este desarrollo y lo pongo como una
una pequeña esperanza digamos que la
carrera espacial a futuro un futuro
lejano va a ser que la tierra signifique
porque va a ser mucho más fácil hacer
una conquista no son tan caros voy a
empezar por otro lado son tan caros los
proyectos que hay que hacer y los
proyectos a desarrollar que no tiene que
hacer la tierra completa no puede ser de
otra manera pero falta muchísimo para
que eso suceda para que tengamos un
futuro estilo viaje a las estrellas star
trek falta mucho tiempo faltan cientos
de años pero bueno estamos empezando
estos son los primeros pasos para
generar eso es costoso usted lo menciona
a claudio y eso me lleva a preguntarle
por el caso de eeuu que es tal vez el
primer caso en el que vemos una
incursión de manos privadas en esta
carrera espacial con el turismo espacial
y con estas naves que están impulsando
diferentes compañías en alianza con la
nasa qué tan exitoso ácida ha sido esta
incursión del sector privado en esta
carrera espacial puede ser un ejemplo
para otros países que desean
incorporarse en esta carrera a través de
una alianza público
y seguramente seguramente porque
justamente los privados tienen en este
momento en eeuu al menos un control
bastante importante de todo lo que sea
lanzamientos fíjese en que la provisión
de la estación espacial internacional
fundamentalmente es de privados de
totalmente diría que de privados
entonces eso se va a ir extendiendo a
otros países sin dudas si rodrigo su
opinión sobre esta incursión de los
privados qué balance puede hacer usted
de la evolución que han tenido estos
programas espaciales desde que llegaron
los millones procedentes de compañías
estadounidenses creo que ha sido súper
importante y como bien mencionaba
claudio ha traído un renacer en términos
de innovar y de probar nuevas
tecnologías como los cohetes
reutilizables que ciertamente abaratan
costos muchas veces las instituciones
gubernamentales no tienen la ni el
financiamiento ni la flexibilidad para
poder intentar cosas nuevas y lo estamos
viendo también en emiratos árabes que si
bien ha comenzado un programa espacial
gran parte de ese financiamiento va
precisamente para atraer empresas que
realicen este tipo de desarrollo
tecnológico como empresas privadas
entonces si bien hay un financiamiento
que va de parte del estado a crear un
programa espacial hay una componente
importante para poder generar en el
fondo este desarrollo tecnológico a
través de los privados y eso ciertamente
está acelerando la carrera espacial y
está dando más flexibilidad y creando
más innovación rodrigo cuando uno mira
la agenda de
incursiones espaciales para el año 2022
uno ve que tal vez el plan de china es
muy ambicioso para para este año es
prácticamente una potencia espacial
emergente en el mundo planea poner en
marcha este a su estación espacial
tiangong para final de este año que
tanta ventaja está tomando china en esta
carrera los planes son millonarios y son
muy ambiciosos si lo que yo he leído
últimamente es que si bien están dando
pasos gigantes en términos tecnológicos
todavía no alcanzan a eeuu en el fondo
espero pero con el nivel de inversión y
la motivación que tienen claramente
están avanzando a pasos bastante
agigantados creo que ayuda bastante que
ellos pueden por el tipo de gobierno y
la estructura ponerse plazos a mediana y
a larga a largo plazo verdad a
diferencia de eeuu donde muchas veces el
financiamiento y estas grandes misiones
que requieren escalas de tiempo que en
el fondo son 234 gobiernos si vas
cambiando de un partido a otro
obviamente puede ir cambiando el enfoque
entonces china tiene esa ventaja y
ciertamente cuando estamos hablando de
volver a la luna y de establecer bases
lunares la proyección es que tanto
estados unidos como china van a estar en
una carrera muy cercana a poder quedar
en el fondo quién llega primero así que
ciertamente china está convertido
después de eeuu en el gran protagonista
de la carrera espacial
claudio desde su punto de vista china
entonces está a punto de convertirse en
la gran potencia espacial que tenemos no
solamente la potencia comercial a nivel
mundial sino también espacial y la
extiende un poco la pregunta para hablar
sobre el tema de la luna porque se
renovó este interés por el satélite
natural de nuestro planeta eeuu ya había
puesto un pie allí y básicamente
abandonó la y de seguir explorando la
luna durante muchas décadas porque se
renovó y bueno vamos vamos por partes y
indudablemente china está pisando muy
fuerte tiene sus problemas porque ya
hemos visto que ya tuvo dos cohetes que
cayeron o sea los impulsores que ya
salieron todas las noticias en 2020 y
hace dos semanas una semana tuvimos el
mar que también cayó o sea tiene algunos
inconvenientes pero evidentemente la
tecnología la tiene como para poder
seguir avanzando y agregó un tema más
antes de ir al otro que comentaste es
que eeuu en la década del 60 aprovechó
que tenía un momento de bajón económico
y comercial en su país para impulsar la
carrera espacial como una manera de
inyectar capital para que se renovará el
país y esto mismo se puede hacer en
otros entonces están haciendo una
carrera no solamente para llegar sino
también para movilizar toda la industria
espacial que después se deriva en un
montón de ventajas para el país de todo
tipo en cuanto a por qué no dejaron de
ir muchos se nos preguntan la gente se
habrán ido de verdad a la luna porque
fueron y después no volvieron más lo que
pasa es que es muy caro en ese momento
en extremadamente caro el lanzamiento de
una nave que fuera poco las apolo
entonces en este momento se está
renovando fundamentalmente porque a la
luna se la toma como una especie de
punto intermedio para ir a marte
entonces es muy difícil la el viaje a
marte porque porque falta muchísima
tecnología que todavía seguramente ni
existe como para poder hacerlo entonces
mucho más fácil ir probando en la luna
que está mucho más cerca podemos algún
inconveniente
regresar a los astronautas en poco
tiempo que cuando están siendo un viaje
directamente a marte son meses de
diferencia entonces de esa manera se
pueden ir probando todo el equipamiento
todas las cosas necesarias como para
después dar el salto planetario hasta
marc
rodrigo su opinión sobre esta
importancia de la luna usted mencionaba
el tema minero y que también debe entrar
dentro de esa regulación a futuro la
luna que nos puede aportar en ese tema
ya lollo claudio lo menciona como un
punto de escala para continuar hacia
marte y hacer diferentes investigaciones
pero la luna más allá de la cercanía y
ser un punto de escala que más nos puede
aportar
bueno ciertamente cuando hablamos por
ejemplo de establecer bases y hacerlo en
el polo sur donde precisamente hay agua
permitiría por ejemplo utilizar el
oxígeno para poder suplir a la vida
humana y también el hidrógeno como
combustible que entonces ya tenemos una
parte de la luna que podemos explotar
para poder permanecer ahí también se
habla por ejemplo de utilizar la
radiación solar que podemos alcanzar en
el ecuador con la cara de la luna que
está apuntando al sol y transmitir esa
energía a la tierra por ejemplo
utilizando ondas de microondas pero
también sirve pensando en el futuro para
poder ir y seguir avanzando la
exploración espacial no solo con fines
científicos sino como bien tú
mencionabas también pueden ser
perfectamente mineros en asteroides
entonces la luna es el primer paso
obligado para poder pensar en un futuro
en el cual no solo haya investigación
científica sino también hay un
aprovechamiento en el fondo del tipo
económico a ver quiero que hagamos un
panorama general para para la audiencia
de france 24 de dos puntos importantes
de estos diferentes programas espaciales
espaciales que hay vigentes en este
momento que es lo que tenemos ahora
disponible en este momento para poder
acceder al espacio exterior es decir en
que podemos ir al espacio ya mencionaba
yo hace unos momentos las naves eyeos
rusas que siguen vigentes y han ido
renovándose a lo largo de los años que
más hay disponible en transporte lo
pregunto porque
china está desarrollando una nave
espacial de gran tamaño en la que espera
llevar a diferente cantidad de personas
y diferentes
módulos para terminar de construir o
agrandar en un futuro su estación
espacial internacional y también eeuu le
está apostando a los drinks géisers que
es como una nueva versión de los de los
transbordadores espaciales pero de
última tecnología y un poco más pequeños
rentables y eficientes comienza entonces
con claudio
bien sí indudablemente cada una de las
agencias se está desarrollando nuevas
tecnologías como para esto es cuestión
de ver spacex las naves que tienen y las
las comparamos conclusiva con el
transbordador espacial son completamente
diferentes se nota que hay una
diferencia tecnológica fenomenal cada
uno está desarrollando cohetes porque el
problema fundamental que hay para
escapar de la de la tierra este es salir
de la superficie terrestre hasta el
espacio
eso requiere cohetes de gran porte y
aparte se necesitan corrientes que
tengan la capacidad de poner muchas
toneladas en órbita por ejemplo china
tiene el cohete los logs de mar que
están utilizando en este momento pueden
poner entre 15 y 25 toneladas en órbita
que es una cantidad enorme todos están
tratando de desarrollar naves similares
como para poder llegar a poner en órbita
lo necesario como para poder utilizar el
espacio cercano ya tenerlo como algo al
utilizar el espacio cercano que todavía
no es del todo así aún con la
estabilización espacial internacional
hay algunas cosas que se tienen que
mejorar y a partir de ahí dar el salto a
la luna rodrigo y en su opinión ya
hablamos del tema de transporte que hay
entonces de lo último que hay de
tecnología para la permanencia del
hombre en el espacio está vigente la
estación espacial internacional rusia ya
dijo que le va a apostar por construir
una por su cuenta ellos ya tienen la
experiencia de la estación mir y china
pues está haciendo lo propio con su con
su estación espacial tiangong en donde
más podemos estar en el espacio
bueno creo que el siguiente gran paso es
claramente llegar a marte y para eso
todavía no tenemos la capacidad
los cohetes lo suficientemente potentes
ni grandes para poder hacerlo en las
estaciones espaciales son importantes se
puede hacer bastante investigación
científica y en el fondo nos permite
estudiar los efectos que tiene vivir en
el espacio para nosotros los seres
humanos pero últimamente creo lo más
interesante lo nuevo que viene es
precisamente esta carrera por intentar a
llegar a marte lo antes posible y space
sex aquí está corriendo con ventaja a
través del desarrollo de su cohete
starship tiene fondo no sólo va a
contribuir a poder llevar muchas
toneladas y contribuir por ejemplo quizá
en el futuro llevar telescopios
espaciales como el del tamaño más grande
que james webb space telescope que es
tan famoso estos días verdad sino
también de poder llevar humano
finalmente al planeta rojo sí creo que
ese es el gran paso que nos quiere
abordar dentro de los próximos diez años
rodrigo pero teniendo ya claro este
panorama del transporte la tecnología
que tenemos disponible para el
transporte para permanecer en el espacio
qué tan factible entonces y qué puede
ser esa conquista por la luna
bueno por la luna en teoría en un par de
años tanto estados unidos como china
dice que van a poder llegar en el fondo
astronautas y poder empezar a armar sus
bases lunares y de aquí a diez años
deberíamos tener bases lunares
funcionando en el polo sur tanto de eeuu
como china al menos eso es lo que esas
son las pretensiones que tienen ambos
ambos países india también ha anunciado
que espera pronto poder enviar una
misión tripulada el primer paso que
tienen que dar entre este y el próximo
año es precisamente lograr una noticia
que funcione porque el anterior fallo
pero el siguiente paso también es enviar
astronautas indio a la luna entonces en
ese sentido creo que estamos avanzando y
ya no solamente estamos hablando de
visitar sino que estamos hablando de
permanencia que tiene un montón de
desafíos nuevos pero que ciertamente nos
va a ayudar después a por ejemplo ir a
marte donde no es fácil volver como
decía a claudio está bastante lejos la
comunicación incluso tarda
aproximadamente 20 minutos en
conectarnos si no quisiéramos conectar
marte con la tierra entonces no es
sencillo es bastante caro pero
ciertamente y me alegro mucho como
astrónomo está en el plan de estas
potencias
y un sueño de la verdad realizado
claudio estamos hablando del programa
espacial de china de los emiratos árabes
de rusia de eeuu donde queda la unión
europea en todo este rompecabezas que
aporta están haciendo desde el bloque
europea desde el bloque comunitario
bueno la ésta también tiene están
dedicándose más a lo que es
investigación de espacio profundo están
desarrollando muchas naves pequeñas como
para investigar asteroides investigar lo
que sean comentadas de hecho ya hubo
varias naves que han lanzado no estoy no
no como que no hay un gran desarrollo en
cuanto a enviar personas al espacio
obviamente sí en órbita pero no no hay
como lo está como claro dónde piensan
llegar en cuanto a la colonización por
humanos directamente en la luna lo que
sí están hablando abiertamente son
estados unidos rusia y china pero
después europa no no lo veo que estén
tan
involucrados en este tema cree usted
claudio que en ese escenario donde haya
en órbita una estación lanzada por rusia
la estación espacial que va a ser
lanzada por china que estos dos países
que aquí en el mundo terrenal aquí en
nuestro planeta son aliados y lo vemos
en diferentes escenarios internacionales
que se genere una especie de competencia
y discrepancias y tensión por la esa
conquista espacial dejando un poco de
lado a eeuu que no va a tener pues tiene
la ambición de llegar a la luna pero
pero rusia va a entrar a competir
directamente con su gran aliado que es
china si es que realmente también se
quedaron con le perdieron la carrera
espacial de la década del 60 así que eso
también debe ser bastante le debe dar
bastante impulso a tratar de hacer ahora
la colonización de la luna con lo que
estábamos hablando antes que comentaba
él rodrigo que es una cosa es llegar y
otra cosa es establecerse llegar ya se
hizo en la década del 60 ahora
establecerse con una base con las nuevas
tecnologías inclusive se están
desarrollando en personas 3d para
construir las estructuras que se
necesiten en la luna y por supuesto
después eventualmente en marte entonces
esta competencia va a ser muy positiva
porque es ese tipo de competencia en la
cual se va para adelante la única manera
de huir es para adelante eso es lo más
importante rodrigo en esta agenda de
prioridades y cómo van avanzando estos
diferentes programas espaciales qué tan
prioritario es poder determinar que hay
vida en otros planetas que el vida en
otras galaxias o la prioridad es
simplemente llegar y colonizar y tratar
de establecer a humanos procedentes de
la tierra procedentes de nuestro planeta
en el satélite natural y de pronto en
unos cuantos años en marte
si es una pregunta es super interesante
porque en el fondo muchas de estas
misiones espaciales como algunas de las
que están financiadas e impulsadas por
la esas precisamente tienen el objetivo
de intentar buscar vida en nuestro
sistema solar visitando por ejemplo
lunas de júpiter saturno tratando de
encontrar lugares donde existen
existirían condiciones para poder
encontrar vida por otro lado aquí en la
tierra los dinosaurios no están entre
nosotros verdad sufrieron una extinción
masiva y uno podría pensar porque esto
no nos podría pasar a nosotros como
humanidad en un futuro no tan lejano y
por lo mismo parece natural de que sí
que queremos seguir como humanidad parte
siendo parte del universo en algún
minuto ya no podamos seguir en la tierra
y sea necesario dar este paso hacia
empezar a colonizar otros planetas
precisamente eso es lo que siempre hay y
los más por ejemplo el creador de spacex
en el fondo cita cuando le preguntan por
qué ir a marte y siempre cuenta de que
bueno querer amarte porque en algún
minuto vamos a necesitar salir de la
tierra precisamente para poder asegurar
nuestra supervivencia como especie
humana
claudio su opinión sobre este tema llama
mucho la atención aquí uno puede entrar
a especular muchas cosas a ponerle
muchos ingredientes de ciencia ficción
pero pero que tan prioritario es esto
encontrar otras formas de vida más allá
de nuestro planeta
si es importante inclusive hay una
ciencia que la astrobiología que se
dedica a estudiar esto lo que pasa es
que tan no es tanto el contacto que uno
buscaría sino que más bien se estudia
por eso parte de la investigación de
james webb del telescopio espacial james
webb es detección de atmósfera social de
la composición química de atmósferas de
otros planetas de esos planetas de
planetas alrededor de otras estrellas
porque eso daría lo que se llama la bio
señal en las bio marcas de la existencia
de vida o sea hay gases que solamente
están asociados a la vida entonces si
uno detecta esos gases es muy probable
que en ese planeta exista vida y eso se
va impulsando es parte es parte de todo
o sea la investigación espacial va
impulsando la búsqueda de vida en la
búsqueda de vida va impulsando la
exploración espacial
muchas de las misiones que se están
llevando a marte desde la vikingo la
primera nave en el año 1976 tenía un
laboratorio para tratar de encontrar por
emisión de gases vida entonces cada una
de las cosas que hacemos no nos lleva a
tratar de encontrar vida más allá de
nuestro planeta vamos llegando ya a la
parte final del programa y me gustaría
cerrar este este bloque hablando del
turismo espacial de cómo se ha
desarrollado lo que ha dejado para estas
compañías esta incursión de las privadas
como ya lo mencionamos en este en este
ámbito
rodrigo su impresión sobre este tema
cómo ha evolucionado puede verse un poco
más factible una masificación del
turismo espacial en unas cuantas décadas
y también otra pregunta que añado sobre
el tema de las leyes quien regula el
turismo espacial sí que creo que ha
evolucionado de forma tan rápida que yo
un simple astrónomo chileno ahora sí
sueña con llegar al espacio en algún
minuto porque claro en este minuto el
pasaje sólo lo pueden pagar millonarios
verdad y gente que tiene mucho dinero
pero así de rápido como está avanzando
todo no sería loco pensar de que en un
futuro no tan lejano personas ciudadanos
comunes y corrientes van a poder acceder
es precisamente esto bueno
te pone en una órbita donde tú puedes
ver la tierra desde el espacio lo cual
es súper emocionante y espero
sinceramente algún día poder ser uno de
esos turistas que vuele y sin tener que
endeudar me de por vida por por supuesto
y en el fondo las reglas todavía están
están como bien discutíamos con claudio
antes por escribirse y es importante
precisamente empezar a regular estos
temas también por ejemplo de los
enjambres satelitales desde el proyecto
stalin de spacex verdad que también está
de alguna manera interfiriendo con la
investigación astronómica o sea hay
tantos tópicos tan nuevos que es
necesario legislar que como humanidad
pronto tenemos que ponernos de acuerdo
claudio que es tan prudente puede ser
entonces llevar este turismo espacial
llevar al espacio a personas del común
que no tienen nada que ver con las
ciencias ni con las investigaciones esto
es práctico o debe ser más bien
reservado para la investigación para el
desarrollo pronto de estos programas y
poder dar un paso grande en la humanidad
de poner un pie en la luna y
establecerse y por qué no pensar en
marte en unas cuantas décadas
que en realidad es algo natural para
nosotros llegar mirar y después querer
establecernos entonces como decía
rodrigo en este momento es
extremadamente caro pero no quita que se
sobre de volar el avión hace 50 años o
100 años era algo para algunos nada más
y hoy es algo lo más natural entonces es
bastante razonable pensar que el turismo
espacial se va a desarrollar mucho y que
va a ser fácil ir al espacio en un no
digo pronto pero en unos una par de
décadas viajar al espacio tiene que ser
algo realmente sencillo y algo que tener
un hotel como para poder establecerse
tiene que ser algo también muy muy útil
e interesante para hacer y fácil claudio
y en cuanto a la legislación siendo
estados unidos el país que está
liderando en el turismo espacial es
probable que sea este país el que
acomoden las reglas de pronto de la
mejor forma que le salga más beneficioso
para ellos como ven ustedes el tema de
la legislación para regularlo
bueno el tema de la regulación es algo
internacional o sea eeuu puede querer
hacer lo que quiera pero hay muchos
intereses en todo eso muchos países hay
que hacer algo que sea para todos y que
sea regular para todos este no no
tenemos idea de nada en cuanto a
reglamentaciones porque porque si
alguien se accidenta en un hotel quien
se hace cargo o porque fue un satélite
que chocó y lo lastimó como se regularía
quien se haría cargo o sea no hay nada
de eso no hay nada porque porque es
nuevo todos estos nuevos estamos en un
espacio nuevo escribiendo la historia
así que tenemos que seguir habrá que
hacer reuniones internacionales como
para con abogados como donde la gente
como para poder ir regulando esto bueno
pues llegamos a la parte final del
programa en nuestro punto de alunizaje
aterrizaje como lo quieran llamar son
las conclusiones de este programa de lo
que puede venir en esta carrera espacial
como lo ve usted y claudio en la ciudad
de buenos aires- su conclusión china
ventaja eeuu apostándole al turismo
rusia tratando de recuperar el terreno
perdido que es lo que vamos a ver en los
próximos meses en esta interesante
carrera espacial
indudablemente china va a crecer de una
manera fenomenal están volviendo mucho
se han dado cuenta que pueden potenciar
como les inicialmente en la década del
eeuu hizo crecer al país
esto genera empleo genera movimientos
económicos genera desarrollo entonces
ellos están apostando directamente a
esto y hemos visto que china no hace
ningún movimiento sin haberlo estudiado
previamente así que es evidente que van
a seguir creciendo muy muy rápidamente
rusia va a tratar de estar en la carrera
y de equipos mejores entonces obviamente
van a tender a hacer cosas más grandes
como violar a la luna directamente y
tiene una larga experiencia en ese
terreno rodrigo lo dejo para el cierre
del programa su conclusión que vamos a
ver acá en un escenario en donde américa
latina no está jugando ningún papel
lastimosamente
lamentablemente y que ciertamente
tenemos mucho trabajo por hacer pero yo
creo que mi conclusión es que ojalá que
toda esta carrera espacial llegar a la
luna estará en el espacio nos permita
mirar abajo
y recordar de que estamos todos juntos
en este planeta es una conclusión o
reflexión que han hecho muchos
astronautas cuando no ven fronteras
desde el espacio y eso nos permita
unirnos aún cuando la situación política
obviamente es muy complicada para poder
enfrentar los grandes desafíos que
tenemos como humanidad como son por
ejemplo el calentamiento global entonces
esa es realmente una mirada más
optimista aquí espero se hagan la vida
en el sur pues a rodrigo ya claudio les
agradezco por haber puesto en
perspectiva habernos
explicado cómo está en este momento los
diferentes programas espaciales y esa
carrera por llegar a la luna oa marte en
un futuro cercano
muchas gracias por haber puesto en
perspectiva el tema para la audiencia de
france 24 ustedes muchísimas gracias por
la sintonía sigan con nosotros
[Música]